tonight one of those exciting things
that happens a first-round draft pick
pitcher gets his major league debut as a
starter david peterson takes the mound
for the meds tonight o2 to alonso
and alonzo down on strikes as hall gets
him with a fastball away and that's the
second out so pete continues to struggle
everyone here is jeff mcneal
up the middle nice sliding stab bogart
spins throws got him
beautifully done by sandra bogart
that's it in the air to left field it's
deep back toward the green monster and
off the wall played nicely by davis his
throw to second base he may get him and
he'll be out by 20 feet
j.d davis playing the karen perfectly
off the green monster and jose perazo is
a dead duck at second base
here's j.d martinez here's payoff pitch
swung on and miss strike three
and they may take that ball out of play
too because it commemorates david
peterson's first major league strikeout
and here's robinson canoe he's had a
tough start 3-2 to canoe and he lines
one the other way from base hit that
ball will go back to the wall davis
around 30 is on the way home cespedes
pulls in at third robinson canoe with an
opposite field double to driving a run
and the mets jump in front one nothing
two out here in the second inning
they've got the bases loaded
oh here's the o2 pitch swing and a fly
ball shallow right here comes pilar will
have to play it on a couple of hops it's
a base hit and two runs are going to
score sespedes is in right behind him is
canoe going all the way to third is nimo
and on at first with a two-run single is
ahmed rosario and the mitts have a three
to nothing lead
david peterson six foot six 240 pounds
chavis pops one up behind first base
conforto coming over toward that corner
and reaches in he's got it terrific play
by michael conforto
jd martinez coming up a base has loaded
nobody out
and peterson gets him swinging on a
slider and jd martinez strikes out for
the second time
so one out base is still full and now
rafael devers now defense hits it
sharply might be two picked up by canoe
goes to second for one as one comes from
and now they've got the runner between
second and third the ball was short
hopped by canoe they got the force at
second and some poor base running by ben
and tendy and he is tagged out it's a
double play the run will count and
that's the third out
so one out and one on now jd davis
and jd flies one toward the right field
corner slicing toward the pesky pole and
it hits the pole for a two run homer j.d
davis off the pesky pole
his first home run of the year
here's peraza first pitch hit on the
ground to second should be two kanoa
second one rosario to first they turn it
double play and that retires the side
well here is kevin palar
the other way he goes and then he's
going to drop in for a hit
rafael devers in the score
pilar will slide into second base with a
run scoring double red sox on the board
for the second time tonight milar
continues to swing it two for three in
the game peterson's first major league
start will end after five and two thirds
innings and 78 pitches job well done by
peterson in his first timeout
2-2
see yes 94 bloom away you're right
struck him out one left
ben attendee in with two down on the
bases empties
and ben and tendy can't catch up with
the cutter from wilson who has himself
an impressive one two three seven on to
the eighth there's nimble with a runner
at second and one out
and he drives one out to right field
that goes pillow and looks up and it's
off the wall around third is jimenez
he's trying to score jimenez to the
plate the throw goes to second nimmo's
got a double and the mets laid six to
two so here's mcneal first ball swinging
lifts it in the air pretty deep to left
center bradley back headed to the wall
and it's off the wall and in play nimo
scores alonzo rounds third he's coming
home there will not be a relay throw two
runs score and standing at second with a
two run double is jeff mcneal lar having
a good night at the plate he's got two
hits
gets a hold of that one
marissa can't get it cut off by conforto
and it's another three hit game for
kevin pilar as he will lead off the
ninth inning with a walk-in double
jackie bradley jr coming up
a little squibber here charging out of
rosario
as the run comes in to score to make it
eight to three but two down an attendee
has walked twice and struck out
now the pitch swung on and fouled
into the middle of ramos strike three
put it in the books